you're fascinated with genealogy you've  done a lot of work on television with  your show talking about who do you think  you are talking about genealogy you  posted a picture the other day of your  great-great-great grandparents yeah do  you want to can we show this you posted  it let's put it up this is an  unbelievable picture that's Shana and  gursha before they died  [Laughter]  and do you know what else why they were  younger than us they were younger than  us in that photo I think yeah I found a  picture the other day of my  great-great-grandmother let's put that  up it's very you can't really see the  resemblance  that family resemblance very strong I  had people riding like oh you look just  like your great-great-great grandfather  what like yeah no put a beard on you and  put you out in the field and  [Laughter]